[Música]
renovada pasión
quiero contarles mi experiencia en el
cubit el 23 de marzo del año pasado
el presidente de la empresa el ingeniero
ariel corniel me llamó del retiro y me
dijo mike está pasando este tema
complicadísimo del comida en todos los
países y no tengo experiencia y quisiera
tu apoyo
y yo me presenté con él con los con los
colegas del consejo directivo y el
comité ejecutivo y le dije mira mi
experiencia ha sido en en los terremotos
en las inundaciones en los huracanes en
la guerra civil pero no tengo
experiencia en pandemia pero que
nosotros sí aprendimos es que se
necesita una dirección firme y
decisiones rápidas y les cuento hoy una
de las mejores decisiones empresariales
de mi vida que tomamos ese 23 de marzo
uno
llamamos y nos comunicamos con todos los
trabajadores en todos los países y les
ofrecimos y prometimos estabilidad en su
trabajo nadie iba a perder su trabajo
por el cob y 19 y realmente no sabíamos
el horizonte
tomamos una decisión de salvar empleos
sin perder vidas es decir trabajar y no
parar de producir
mejoramos dramáticamente el sistema de
entregas y home delivery nos dedicamos a
preservar el cash mantener la cartera al
día y girando las líneas
nos dedicamos a ganar mercado
vimos que todos los competidores estaban
confundidos y desorientados y las
personas iban a regresar a quedarse en
su casa y que hay una oportunidad para
vender más pintura también usamos todas
las redes y todos los sistemas de
comunicación para comunicarnos con los
empleados con los clientes con los
distribuidores con los proveedores
es el gran problema que se toman esas
decisiones primero es un ambiente
desconocido
pasamos de una pandemia a una endemia la
parte científica no preservó sino que la
mayoría de información era de redes sin
respaldo no científicas los políticos
tomaron muy malas decisiones
no fueron científicas no fueron técnicas
no había filtros para decidir y al final
toda la población se llenó de miedo
ahora que les puedo contar que fue el
resultado el resultado fue maravilloso
el grupo nuestro creció a doble dígitos
empleamos más de 300 personas en el año
del cob y del año pasado y quedamos
mucho más fortalecidos después de la
crisis es decir tomamos una buena
decisión
pero hoy
2021 estamos en post co vida y entonces
yo lo que quiero contarles a ustedes es
de esta renovada pasión y lo voy a
dividir en tres quién
quien debemos escoger como lo debemos
hacer y cuánto
la pregunta más importante es a quien
ponemos al frente
en esta crisis pasada nos enseñó que
habían tres grupos de ejecutivos y de
funcionarios en el consorcio aquellos
grupos que tomaron el liderazgo y fueron
los ganadores estos líderes que
sobresalieron un grupo de personas que
se desorientó perdió se confundió y
perdió el espíritu se desarmaron
pobrecitos y en medio del grupo más
grande el que veamos los zombis sé que
las personas que ya no sabían qué hacer
están esperando instrucciones se
quedaron a las cargadas con la crisis y
son las que los líderes deben enfrentar
luego también que debemos entender que
sólo queremos aquellos que quieran
aprovechar esta nueva pasión que sean
los sobrevivientes
y nosotros debemos tener la habilidad de
reconocer a los líderes que en ese
momento sacaron adelante los negocios a
todo nivel es importantísimo que ese
líder no sólo ese líder empresarial fue
el líder en su comunidad fue líder en su
familia fue líder en su empresa fue el
líder en su nación es el liderazgo real
que sacó la crisis
en el caso nuestro es mucho más fácil
identificar aquellos líderes porque
tenemos métodos de medición y vimos los
resultados
entonces hoy mi recomendación es que
nombren lo y pongan a estos líderes
después de su premio de la crisis al
frente de la nueva época esa pasión
renovada que empieza hoy
en este quién es muy fácil nosotros
entendemos que hay unos que se quedaron
cotidianos o estos pobres zombis el
líder es el que los va a cambiar a ellos
no importa su antigüedad ni su jerarquía
no recomiendo una organigrama ni
recomiendo nuevas funciones ni más
departamentos
simplemente nombrar a los líderes y
darles el poder
esto me da a mí la fuerza del quien
luego vendría como
tenemos que entender que es un mundo
cambiado hay nuevos consumidores nuevos
hábitos entonces lo que sí tenemos que
hacer si cualquier medida de
sustentabilidad si tenemos que usar la
tecnología en el negocio si tenemos que
utilizar la automatización sin utilizar
todas las herramientas de modernidad si
saltos en las herramientas tecnológicas
si utilizar los hábitos nuevos de las
redes sin entender las horas de tráfico
y el trabajo si la velocidad de
respuesta
y la personalización hacia cada cliente
entonces entendimos que para hacerlo hay
que entender el contexto que hay el
cambio de los consumidores y el cambio
de la dinámica pero podemos ver al
extranjero y aprender podemos ver a los
competidores qué cosas hicieron buenas
podemos pensar en servicios alternos y
parecidos aprendamos que hicieron que es
ganador y cambiante tenemos que
aprovechar y capitalizar las lecciones
ese es el cómo y luego nosotros con
nuestros nuevos líderes hacer ese plan
de invasión
la tercera pregunta de hoy es cuando
cuando
estamos en el mes de octubre
nosotros dijimos en marzo se acabó el
pensamiento cotidiano
empieza el pensamiento post cobit porque
porque desde diciembre hay posibilidades
de vacuna y la vacuna elimina los casos
críticos
entonces tenemos que pensar en una época
post cotidiana
agarré una su caja de zapatos pongan sus
historias los recortes de periódico todo
lo que vivieron y guarden yo recomiendo
una cinta de masking tape o una cinta de
cinta adhesiva de color intenso que la
pongan en la puerta de su institución de
su oficina o de su casa o del negocio
que diga antes de kobe después de kobe
como decir antes de cristo después de
cristo para que todos los días nos
recordemos que nuestro mindset tiene que
cambiar a una nueva época
es importantísimo entender que el tiempo
que nos regía antes cambio usábamos
métodos de planeación anual
mediciones mensuales reportes
existen al menos 52 semanas al año no
señores hoy estamos nosotros en un nuevo
tiempo todo el día cuenta mejor usamos
utc tiempo universal 24 horas al día de
lunes a domingo tenemos que cambiar no
podemos seguir el método anterior y
empieza hoy
yo siento que es la oportunidad de
empezar en realtime en verdadero tiempo
real y con esto empezamos la nueva época
que empieza hoy
esta lección que hoy les quiero dar tuvo
frutos de marzo para ahora estamos en
crecimiento también de doble dígito nos
está yendo muy bien con esta decisión y
quiero compartir se la son tres cosas
primero nombrar a los líderes como los
escogemos con los que sacaron la tarea
en el commit número dos darle
lineamientos de cómo hacerlo básicos y
número tres empezar hoy
y yo quiero decirles que esto nos lleva
a una renovada pasión empresarial y de
servicio hay que renovar la inversión
hay que inyectar el positivismo hay que
invertir en las personas el día de hoy
les transmito este mensaje con mi
experiencia que fue positiva quiero
darles a todos muchas gracias y
recordarles que tenemos que empezar en
el post commit con una renovada pasión
[Aplausos]
[Música]